il a existé avant toi bien sûr et toi tu
as donné avant moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
Laurent Brian Molko utilise sa carte de
bon client que tu l'as donné la dernière
fois donc il vient quand il veut ça va
Bryan
tu peux venir quand tu veux voilà merci
la dernière fois que tu es venu il y
avait Sacha Distel et ce soir il y a
Hervé Vilard
vous avez un point commun tous les deux
plat mais au moins un c'est que comme
Hervé Vilard tu as été Bryan ami avec un
prêtre c'est
des petits séminaires ensemble à
l'époque
non et puis toi le problème c'est que 14
ans tu as découvertes sexualité tu as
oublié les curés
[Rires]
je t'assure on va rentrer mais en fait
c'est peut-être cet enfant se proche de
ce curé qui a fait que dernièrement tu
as fait un disque qui s'appelle sleeping
with Ghost c'est à dire dormir avec des
fantômes c'est ce mysticisme peut-être
qui est revenu
ça avec moi j'ai toujours
je suis reconnaissante ça je suis je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui qui
m'a beaucoup aidé avec avec l'écriture
et des métaphores bibliques c'est
quelque chose de très très fort alors je
suis oui on peut faire de très belles
chansons il y a de très belles choses
dans la Bible à chanter ouais mais dans
la Bible il y a plein d'inceste violent
ils sont allés vraiment creuser au fond
des choses
la dernière fois Brian Molko c'est très
bien entendu que Sacha Distel et ce soir
je pense que tu vas très bien attendre
Villard c'est quand même l'émission
c'est l'émission du choc des cultures
voilà alors cet album sleeping with
gosst réédité avec 10 reprises de grands
standards internationaux il y a Johnny
et Marie de Robert Palmer il y a mélodie
Nelson de Serge Gainsbourg Daddy Cool de
Boney M parce qu'avec extraordinaire de
voir placebo qui joue du Boney M et puis
aussi la réédition
en français d'un morceau qui s'appelle
protective le mode I want qui s'appelle
protège-moi en français avec des paroles
de Virginie Despentes
alors depuis que vous êtes venus Bryan
dans cette émission il y a à peu près un
an
j'ai lu un article une interview de vous
avec Étienne Daho dans Rolling Stones et
vous vous énervez contre la téléréalité
vous dites que c'est une insulte à la
pop vous dites ça devrait pas s'appeler
à la recherche de la nouvelle star par
exemple ça devrait s'appeler à la
recherche du nouveau chanteur de karaoké
c'est qui qui en profite vraiment c'est
d'accompagner le téléphone c'est la
maison disque et puis c'est la compagnie
de télé et c'est pas vraiment
il y a toujours eu un type qui était là
derrière pour ramasser le pognon Claude
François ou qui tu veux même si tu les
connais pas
ou Lucienne Boyer ou ils ont pas ramassé
le magot d'abord
on ne fait pas ce métier avec la
télévision la télévision n'est pas
représentative de notre métier nous
chantons
il dit maintenant c'est la télévision
qui fait ce métier non c'est faux c'est
faux totalement faux
je connais des artistes sont des
musiciens extraordinaires du Nord ouais
il s'appelle il s'appelle les mauvaises
langues ils sont devant 3000 personnes
ils sont jamais passés à la télé il y a
un public en France extraordinaire il
tanquera du linge aux fenêtres tant
qu'on pourra chanter
plus à payer
mais si on m'invite à Star Academy
pourquoi pas mais à la limite je pense
que les momes ont le droit de rêver par
contre tu as le droit de revendiquer tu
as le droit de rêver d'accord c'est de
revendiquer c'est de changer de coiffure
qui Hervé Vilard aujourd'hui ça sera
emmerdant non
mais ce qui dit aujourd'hui lui dit que
finalement il y a le show business est
lié à la télé qui est lié à une
compagnie de téléphone et finalement
tout ça
le show business n'a jamais été dans la
chanson Thierry le show-business il est
ailleurs il est pas dans la chanson la
différence c'est que
la différence c'est que les gens
vraiment y pensent que ils ont le droit
d'être célèbre sans pas bosser c'est ça
c'est ça et je pense que c'est ça que la
France recherche une star et Star
Academy c'est ça c'est l'idée qui met en
tête des jeunes alors
et ça crée un malaise social qui est la
jalousie de la célébrité et à l'âge de
21 ans les jeunes filles se rencontrent
qui vont pas se marier avec le capitaine
de l'équipe de football d'Angleterre
David Beckham par exemple et puis il
tombe dans la dépression c'est c'est un
malaise culturel je pense et les gens
oublient la musique n'est pas une
compétition de popularité
c'est moi je pense que c'est la base
c'est la base
et c'est quelque chose parce que j'ai eu
peur vraiment que ça se passe pas aussi
bien que quelque chose et puis j'ai
l'impression que ça peut aussi ça se
passe
les gens les gens pensent que vraiment
le rock n' roll par exemple c'est que le
sexe drogue bien sûr que ça existe dans
ce monde-là mais c'est de la bosse
vraiment on passe 18 mois en tournée on
se casse les couilles pour vendre des
disques il a existé avant toi bien sûr
et toi tu as donné avant moi aussi il
t'a donné de la musique il t'a donné la
musique et écoute Lou Reed moi ça peut
paraître étonnant mais je j'écoute
j'écoute Laurie depuis très longtemps
était épané bon je crois qu'on va pas
arriver à vous réconcer ça va
j'écouterai 110
alors Bryan vous êtes devenu célèbre en
transformant votre angoisse d'adolescent
le teenage hangst en art et on va voir
comment ça s'est passé on va faire une
interview trash
[Musique]
tout à partir de quel âge avez-vous
commencé à vous maquiller
un Verlin
je faisais du théâtre à l'école alors
j'ai toujours associé la scène avec le
maquillage
est-ce que vous avez déjà porté un
string en cuir
un string en cuir non jamais
est-ce que vous avez déjà bu du sang
jamais non
j'ai une copine j'avais une copine il y
a cinq six ans qui a bu mon sang mais
j'ai jamais bu le sang de quelqu'un
d'autre
est-ce que tu as déjà porté des menottes
ailleurs que dans un commissariat oui
bien sûr
et toi
est-ce que tu t'es déjà filmé en train
de faire l'amour jamais non
j'ai pas envie que ça se retrouve sur
Internet
est-ce que tu as déjà sucé des talons
aiguilles
non j'ai léché des bottes mais jamais si
c'est des talents aiguilles est-ce que
tu as déjà partagé une copine avec des
potes
en sachant non est-ce que tu as déjà
porté des vêtements de ta mère oui
est-ce que tu t'es déjà auto mutilé
j'aimerais bien et la capacité de faire
l'autofellation et puis je me suis
ostéopathe c'est pas bon pour les
lombaires il faut le répéter
donc est-ce que tu sais déjà auto mutilé
ben oui oui je l'ai fait ouais
exclusivement d'être super sérieux pour
un instant mais
je suis dépressive j'ai beaucoup
souffert de ça j'ai pris pour longtemps
des médicaments pour et
ouais il y avait des temps
très noir dans ma vie où je me suis
autotomie
je me retrouvais dans des chambres des
chambres d'hôtels et je cassais des vins
et je coupais méchant mais heureusement
ça va mieux ces jours-ci
c'est important d'en parler parce que
c'est vraiment très important que je
pense que les jeunes sachent que des
gens comme moi ont passé par des choses
dans lesquelles il passe aussi parce que
moi
j'ai souffert d'une maladie qui est la
dépression et puis
ça veut pas dire que c'est pas possible
de faire quelque chose de positif
même si il y a quelque chose qui est
dans sa tête ou qui qui t'arrête ou qui
qui te force à tailler ou de te patiner
et j'espère que je suis une inspiration
pour les gens c'est pour ça que j'en
parle je trouve que c'est super
important
est-ce que Brian est-ce que tu t'es déjà
rasé les poils du torse
de photos si tu as dû le faire toi aussi
pourquoi pour le Strip c'est pas très
esthétique
est-ce que tu as déjà regardé
Jean-Pierre Pernaut à 13h pardon
et mettez un pouce bleu